[Music]
hey i'm janelle presina and i was on big
brother six and big brother all-stars
congratulations janelle i hold the
record for most competition wins in a
season
five powers of vetoes and four hohs
all right janelle number four
i'm back for more with number four well
the only reason i did decide to come
back is because it's an all-stars cast
which is super fun because i played in
the very first all-stars and i know that
you know the producers have a lot in
store for us so it was
very exciting for to hear that it was
all stars so i said yes
you said they have a lot of store in
store for us a bit ominously
a bit fearfully what do you think is in
store for you well it's usually just a
bigger like the first all-stars that i
played i remember everything was just a
little bit
bigger like you know the hohs were a
little bit more extravagant
there was just it was just a it was just
like a big bang
there was just a lot more to the show
how much do you want to finally win one
or do you not care anymore i absolutely
want to win
obviously i wouldn't come back if you
know my head and heart wasn't in it to
win it
but this time i actually just want to
have a ton of fun with it too
anybody who you're excited to see
nervous to see
um so i don't know who the cast is but
i would love to see anyone that i've
worked with before or been an alliance
with
um anyone that i've played with before
that could potentially have like a
little secret alliance with
knowing this was all stars that your
mind had to wander who would you hope to
see to form an alliance with and who
if you see them there are you gonna be
like oh crap
i would 100 form an alliance with dan
if he doesn't win big brother 14 it's an
absolute travesty
so are you saying that dan was um the
greatest player
in this game in 14 seasons of the game
no
i would say that dan's hands down one of
the best players of all time
i've played with him before he's one of
the best to ever play the game
so i would love to see dan in the house
um
some other players some big players like
danny donato
i know that she's like a beast in comps
so if she were in the house
i would definitely i feel like i could
work with her okay
so uh you were on the first all-star
season how much of a leg
up does that give you going into this
next one having played
all-stars before so i've played
all-stars before i also
believe that i have more experience than
anyone because i played this will be my
fourth time
so i have a ton i'm like as a veteran as
veteran can get
so i definitely have a leg up on the
competition
because i've played so many different
seasons there's so many different
scenarios
there's only 10 and 11. and then there's
three slices
so you can have somebody sleep on the
floor with no nothing what do you mean
i don't know we'll figure out later what
strategy are you heading in with are you
changing things
up at all going in with something new
based on your experience or sticking
with what works
so i'm obviously going to stick with
what works for strategy but i mean
as far as what i'm going to do you know
completely strategy wise i need to see
who's in the house
i don't know who's in there so it really
depends on what players they put in the
house
for me to potentially work with i mean
one thing that is different of course is
uh
there's never been any season of big
brother in the middle of a global
pandemic
right how much do you think that affects
the game
how much does it affect people mentally
emotionally physically
i mean i think being a pandemic
definitely affects people emotionally
and mentally they
might be thinking you know what's going
on in the world is my family
okay hopefully their head's not all the
way in it
yeah well i mean you guys already know
what quarantine is like the rest of the
world figured out a little bit what it's
like to be yes
yes i have have you talked
about that with people in your life like
are they telling you wow i finally kind
of understand what it must be like to be
in the house
i mean i think i sent out a tweet like
early on like day two of the
stay-at-home order
and i think my tweet said something like
oh yeah throw me a house with no phone i
mean i play big brother for
fun this is fun for me like i love it
i mean look usually you guys are heading
into the house having been
living life and spending normal days
with family and friends and all that now
everybody's coming off of
months in lockdown tested of being
sequestered after testing
where people's heads gonna be at i mean
i think mentally a lot of people might
not be as strong because they've been
locked down for so long i mean truly i
am an introvert by nature
so for me i absolutely love quarantine i
love being locked away
it makes me mentally stronger than ever
i've got all the tips for winning
if you're mentally stronger than ever
how cut throat are you getting this time
around
so this time around i want to play super
cutthroat because it's my last hurrah so
i want to go with the bang
okay just going out with a bang need
winning yes
definitely winning is in my hopefully
future
and are you putting this on the record
you would never play again even if
you're asked back after now
i would never i said that before though
[Laughter]
i did say that before i didn't think
they'd call me back
so um i was shocked i was like oh wow
okay
uh well what was your reaction when you
got that call why do you think they did
call you back well it's so funny because
i did the amazing race
two summers ago and a lot of the women
got eliminated early on
because we weren't you know obviously as
strong as the men
and i remember rachel riley saying oh my
gosh uh if there's an all-stars
cast like i cannot wait to do it i want
to play so bad
and she was like britney would you do it
britney said no
and then she was like janelle would you
and i said no i wouldn't so at that time
two years ago i would have said no but
i'm in a different place in life now
since doing big brother i've gotten
married and i've had a baby oh she just
threw up on me
i'm the real housewife of minnesota
things change i'm in a totally different
place
my kids are a little bit older too so i
don't have that um you know what i mean
like they're
a little bit older yeah they're not like
little little you are this beloved
player from the franchise and you have a
house guests who look up to you
what do you think it'll be like for you
to interact with people who
might idolize you do you just get savage
with them and use that to your advantage
i mean here's the thing i have for the
longest time
had such a great relationship with any
alumni that i come in contact
with so for the most part every person
has
you know leave me a super positive like
oh my gosh no we love you i mean i've
sent baby shower gifts i've been to
weddings
so i know there's a hopefully a lot of
people in the house that i could
potentially work with that they could
they look up to me any concerns about
uh competing with people from more
recent seasons
i feel like the house guests that were
on a more recent season
may have a little bit leg up on some of
the older players
from years past because the competitions
have changed quite dramatically
um they're more glitchy they're more
gamey there's more lights
there's more action they're more
physical than ever
um so and i think the game moves a lot
faster because there's more competitions
now like i'm used to a ton of downtime
and i think that people that are from
newer seasons are used to
a faster paced game what's it gonna be
like to step back into the house to see
julie
is it emotional is it triggering i think
stepping into the big brother house for
me
is my second home i absolutely love
playing the game i put my heart into it
and i get excited seeing julie i get
excited seeing the house i already know
which bedroom i want to sleep in
besides the hoh so i'm super pumped
what went through your mind when you
found out they were doing another
all-stars i mean what makes all stars
just so much better and it's how awesome
is it that they're doing it again for
the first time in a long time
so when i first got the call i
definitely wasn't a yes immediately i
had to
process the information for about
i think it was like two or three weeks i
processed the information and i was a
maybe i told him put me down as a maybe
because i had to think about it and i
had to think about what i would go into
this all-stars cast with
if i could win because it's going to be
harder than ever it's my fourth time
playing
so i'm gonna be a huge target if i even
had a chance at winning so
there was a lot of a lot of thoughts and
i had to process it
and then i thought i thought to myself
gosh
i don't want to live life saying no to
all stars i want to say
i want to go for it and i want to play
my hardest that i've ever played
and give it my all what do you want to
prove to everybody to the audience and
to the fellow players
something that i want to prove is you
can do anything at any age i am 40 now
so i'm older than you know it's been 15
years since my very first season
um you can be just as good as a
competitor and
a game player 15 years after your very
first season
what message do you have to your fellow
house guests who you haven't met yet
what do they need to watch out for
watch out for me i am i'm sweet to your
face but i'm telling you this time
it's gonna be a little bit trickier i'm
outta here see you guys later
given that it's all stars you guys are
coming off of again
the pandemic this being a crazy time in
our country yeah it's political it's an
election year
what do you think the vibe in the house
will be like could this be the most
intense season ever
i absolutely think this could be the the
best and most intense season ever
i mean our country is on high alert like
things are happening
that are it's going to make the history
books so this is an exciting exciting
time this is going to be the best
season of big brother ever